did you raise alain also,
for example, cup première ficc
leap communities in fact there is a mix
between yes the raddho if it plays a
very important role in the suburbs in
general in the estates also it changes
and the French there is  for example when
I was in France it was funny because
there were the parents of my ex
girlfriend who in fact you couldn't
understand for example you weiler me no
it's very typical to read you worship that
mean you piss me off now it
got complicated for the peas some
people from another generation of
compromise it's a mix between i
think it's arabic it's not
only art because french  there's a
lot of immigration it's changed
it's modifying French and so I think
it doesn't leave anyone indifferent
so I was wondering if depression
for example that you understand that
lately it's one of his
expressions but he  there is a lot in fact
that fun
for example a  rounded girl to say
a year on Tuesday while dying very
elegant it's not very elegant whose ten
years I met a girl eating said
I caught to say gp we manage to say
skirt and hot for example in discotheque
we say j  've sinned to say i caught
i found a hot or bus anna ggp
where i'm torched is what they say i
'm torched in a tutu is drunk for
example i'm torch and no no i
'm all good under  it's said in France
too but it's funny to say I'm
wiped so at first I didn't understand
forked that's off the screen and is
what you say for example for field and
mops I have a friend who told me
that  in fact in brussels so much
singing and serving it's not the same thing
so much in france so there is even a
use
the same vouchers that are used
the initiation to the different how
do you say fountain for example is
it true  that we say drinking trough
and to let oneself be harassed for
example I harassed u  no one is
what you say harassed or buying the
islands it's true you also say
instead of saying i'm 18 i'm 18
when i just tell you i'm 18 gold
so its skis vick has a  such a
strong influence of language is what because if
you say to a point where indeed
there are several examples like that of
many Quebecers who are not even
aware that Quebecois and effluents
it is still quite strongly
from English another  shows examples that
comes to mind is take a
walk that there is in english as long
as king take a walk
i think we had there are a lot of
regretful words we use
for that  I'm giving you my appointment
so what the teacher is playing pinball in
a disciplined way
I don't have a mop serves all
that in plain sight and I think it's not
on the trunk the post office no no you say
quite clearly like  his children
no no I couldn't have in fact the
laptop
so it looks like a laptop they call me  milk
on the laptop and then you asked
me what you say that in france but i
'm me i'm italian miss if i
live in france there's no one says
laptop so sam these five questions
as interesting for people
normally as i had  written I
say it if in italy we want to learn for
example spanish ends up compared
to spanish from spain because all
the races in spain in spain is
the same thing it goes for french
is what  'there are resources
are there books for Quebec French
because I know that there are a
lot of people who, for example, want to
live notabilité in canada and are starting
to set themselves apart from films of course
this is what  that there are grammars or the
grammar several it's the same thing
but I mean the pronunciation on
told me that there are many more
vowels as excluding everything
to face the pronunciation quebecois
when there is  months never
heard of the al  exandre couture he is
a friend of the polyglot community he
had I think he had written a
book where he wrote a book celebrating
is what you know do you
know him what do you also know of  other
books for people who are
interested in Quebec French
so indeed alexandre cloutier
ugly since a post on beni's blog
so for those who know the frost
so you can't really find
them alix de québec's book
and then I  I looked on the internet to
find resources concerning
Quebec French and Puivert it's
quite minimal as a
collection I looked at his house for
example
and then I found 2 2 lille who we do
n't have too much pain in the ass  also quebec
link we can also put the links
after 1.3 of places genres and styles which
is directly the insipid quebec
last two sentences quebec dictionary
in facebook logical smoothing and isabelle
martin so that's a lot of resources
that I found there were others
but some were very proud of them
from the 90s the early 90s
so I think it would not be very
good in front of a website that works very
very well so I asked them  to all
its models linkebeek frank and then
the website it's the msj had a wpm
points like beard the players of quebec
d'art french slash
so it's for my metro signed and then
I looked at the final website  sam to the
very interesting in tapes of
audio data but most of
all practice very well great these
young people quebec films
through
yes because in fact with the internet everything
is possible now i think the
way i think my best  in
fact, learning Quebec is about
immersing yourself in the culture
I think that if you can read
series, for example, it's
very good too,
apart from the books of the books, that's
important  gives you reference in
general a p  important reference anointed
but in general I think the same
spoken with Quebecers
anyway with the internet I said all the
time everything is possible so I don't know how
to decide you're going to contact a Quebecer
you're not going you're going to talk to us a  ok
lesgoirres and I think that Quebecers
are also interesting you go so
especially if you live and in canada and
that's it because I thank you very
much for this very
interesting interview and I remind you that sam
he is also a  lover of languages ​​he
speaks
you speak we have already done an interview
in english you speak it is very very
good and upa korean if not fluent
five years is good if you still live
and anyway i heard that
corian that of languages  the most
difficult in the world and that's worth it I
think it's passed it's for the
culture but also for the
language registers it's a bit complicated and not to
pass my grammar edition because
formulating sentences
the p  problem is the difference in
culture excitement
learning Japanese I realize that the
culture is very different and there no it
is reflected no in the culture is
reflected in the language too so
you also have to know how to  address
people and all that no I don't know if it's
true that if you for example register
you use bergues that are not
appropriate to the context maybe they
only go to excess they can save that
it's just I  don't know honestly I
don't know more experience than
myself foreign site by god don't forgive
you even if you're from the south you're foreign I
read in japan I guess they know
that we are foreigners so it's
it's normal to make mistakes but
in general everything is very
understanding but they can
that's what it can shock or it can
surprise them more to take them by
surprise for example who starts
talking to a person who comes over
and then  you use u  n register
conversation between friends at the warehouse at
105 levels of depending on who you
talk to leave this address it's
complicated because never used
the do you have I missed the
register do you have  have you ever
found yourself in situations a bit
like that people look at you a little
older but what is he saying what is he saying
I liked it happens that but it happens
to me to think even happens  what sometimes the
careers are not too much on what
register here it is so it is very close
it is very subtle as a difference
sometimes depending if you were
with a friend that you concern my close friend
so it will be necessary to correct what
what's more, we hide to
provoke it so it's very subtle like
what sometimes it's very difficult to
know which register is what I owe
apologies and therefore of several several
that I was wrong but I
heard  I do not know once again
that unlike Japan the  s people
speak English quite well because
it's true or it's a legend a myth
maybe being from the city I
think it changes a lot there is really a
lot of money that is put
into teaching English  English wrong and
I really have a big business very
big demonstration
so in general the students of
primary schools with body and these days
by English I would say not well I would not go
until precisely there but have
certainly orders
meyer much better than the design of the
incomparable result
on the other hand the generation of people
who are around 30 years old or more
is normally it is very rare to
find people who speak
English
it is good and then it is so
different  it is to treat all and for
nothing to learn English so basically
when I arrived in Korea for
example if you meet a person
who speaks English to his needs does
he not want the English alex loire where
the  younger generations  very open
no I want to go practice or not very
well I know asthma so it
often happens to me sometimes when I see a
word for example to shop for
shoes for clothes and then the
clerk is quite young in his twenties
and then I talk to him a little nothing and then
I tell him so how does it cost what
to refer you for the imam's hand
was on my blog
which therefore a person who wants to practice
his English
no one else can practice and
then both  people are a conflict
of interest and about fall there
what can you tell us again the
name of the blog
so that's the sauce I assure you that
it's a very interesting block so that
thank you thank you once again  and is good
thank you to you that we have in front of us to see
listen and we will settle down next
time maybe in Korean I don't know if
I decide 24 to learn Korean yes
in fact it's my idea it's  is
to learn the believer but not
now now because  i
am learning japanese if i
start taking korean also
with japanese knew a bit of a mess
when but i plan to learn
the area because otherwise she who
interests me c  is very good I like it
way it's me in my list I
think it's very interesting that's where
we can call it the first part
I think we can do another one
especially if  people are interested in
all that and they can ask us
questions we can make another
hearing without problem it's free
it's easy and it's interesting to
see everything